[Applause]
welcome back to tuba dismounts by
popular demand I'm gonna die a lot of
people wanted me to go back to the
regular face because they couldn't tell
what was going on with the bobblehead my
new object and this is the new improved
mind film you don't be taking the likes
of me with your wheel it's old man there
okay never mind
well these other cards they know what's
up they don't want to touch this
[Music]
okay boogie bus cannot be beaten
especially by you mr. wall
oh are you feeling good about your life
decisions okay does anybody want a piece
of me my mommy always said look both
ways before traffic kills you Oh who's
my bud bud come back but I need you for
things and stuff there's time to dig
around here I gotta get through a bush
okay so far so bad okay
[Music]
green means go
memory loss from last time this happened
oh well I'm gonna put turbo pads on this
[ __ ] I'll be able to go to me well
seriously what the hell is this supposed
to be I'm holding on for dear BAE I hope
you have insurance hope I get I got one
Punk
oh god I think they're trying to tell me
something
[Music]
okay just behead that's great at least I
was beautiful and elegant
[Music]
I just gotta get more speed up okay
there how's my ride could you come okay
never mind
stay in the damn car for two seconds oh
yeah real good there okay bye car have
fun at school oh you're bad nothing is
able to frickin make it through this
stupid though oh I got nothing better to
do Wow go birdie go okay bye
okay right oh my goodness hello oh
[Music]
alright so that was another awesome
episode of turbo dismount thank you all
so much for watching check out the other
episodes of turbo dismount in the
playlist below what is happening over
there thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]